a few words on the southern neighborhood  indeed the mediterranean region  has a strategic importance for the  european union  both our security and stability are  intertwined  we decided to renew our partnership  first of course in fighting this  pandemic  together this is why we have mobilized  over 2.3 billion euros  in support and this is my second point  our renewed partnership includes an  economic and investment plan for the  southern neighborhood  it aims to support long-term social  economic recovery  and to accompany sustainable and digital  development  in the region and beyond these two  elements we will of course  continue to engage with our partners  across the  all the areas where we share common  challenges  you